on tv on radio and on your smartphone
this is talk tv
[Music]
[Music]
good evening i'm pierce morgan
uncensored tonight a jaw-dropping world
exclusive interview with a true
hollywood legend
mickey wrote was once the hottest
property in hollywood smash hit 80s
movies like nine and a half weeks aren't
you gonna ask me how i like this
angelharp you want me to check it out
check it out catapulted into the top of
tinseltown's a-list
his brooding heartthrob was hailed as
the new marlon brando
but his sparkling on-screen stardom
mastered dark reality
raised by an abusive stepfather and
played by mental health problems dwarf
feuding with co-stars directors
producers and well pretty much everybody
else in late after burning every bridge
in hollywood
walked lost it all
battled alcoholism and drug abuse to
second marriage to the model karyotis
ended in acrimony the tordry details
played out in the tabloids a
foreshadowing of his friend johnny depp
split from amber heard
it was a failed attempt to revive
teenage dreams of being a professional
boxer
that robbed him of his good looks
[Applause]
and the heart frog became has been but
after a lost decade in the hollywood
interland and with some questionable
plastic surgery defied the odds he
rebuilt his career
and his life
the 2005 movie since city was not likely
smash hit
i love hip man no matter what you do to
them you don't feel bad
in 2008 played an aging fighter mounting
an ill-advised comeback in the wrestler
which earned him an oscar nomination
you're my girl
you're my little girl
and now
i'm an old broken down piece of meat
two years later he featured alongside
another comeback killer hollywood robert
downey jr in iron man 2.
oh
that's what i wanted
i hear that
there has been was now once again a hot
shot
the roles in big budget hits have kept
him in the public dive
i could do that yeah
hey this is our guide and so two of his
very public controversies and feuds
nikki rourke is never in the shadows for
long
now despite his multiple shots of
redemption mickey rourke still caught
controversy he also has an opinion on
almost everything this sensational
interview made headlines across the
planet and when you see it you'll
understand why it's so compelling i
actually kept the cameras rolling in our
conversation long after the first part
of the interview was supposed to end so
tonight we're bringing it all to you in
full mickey rook opens up on living
through covid
the kobe thing actually
helped me out a little bit because i was
able to go around all the different
sports shops and get all the workout
equipment i needed for
close to a year and a half so i did
nothing but like train for
you know
45 minutes twice a day and did a lot of
reading and
soul searching
it talks about his violent childhood
i came from a very
shameful upbringing and it was very
violent and very physical
abuse and mental
and i
when i left home at like 14 or 15
i didn't realize
i was so happy that the the physical
pain was over because that was
horrifying
i asked him about the success of his
contemporary tom cruise mickey when you
see someone like tom cruise
you know grossing a billion dollars with
top gun
maverick the sequel
35 years or so after the first one what
do you think of that
that doesn't mean to me the guy's been
doing the the same
part for 35 years you know there's you
know i mean
i got no respect for that
he also revealed a secret visit from the
secret service there's one big reason
for that but i'm not going to go into it
because i don't need another visit from
the secret service
and he opened up about his controversial
comments in support of russia's vladimir
putin all this mayhem and this death and
this killing
i didn't see that when i was at the
children's home
with the little kids that all had cancer
and and he was so genuine and empathetic
and
and and
i saw
someone who really cared now people
might be mad at me for saying something
like that but we start at the beginning
mickey's shocking upbringing how his
teenage years were laced with violence
and abuse and the decision he made at 14
but has impacted his life ever since
mickey opens up on what he learned from
23 years in therapy the iconic actors he
idolizes and where he views his own
career trajectory right now standby for
uncentred opinion
cast strength views
and yes what mickey really thinks of tom
cruise
how have you been i've interviewed you
numerous times over the years you look
in great shape
yeah i uh
the kobe thing actually
helped me out a little bit because i was
able to go around all the different
sports shops and get all the workout
equipment i needed for
close to a year and a half so i did
nothing but like train for
you know
45 minutes twice a day and did a lot of
reading and
soul searching and
i had
kind of tried to figure uh well
i was working on a game plan for the
third chapter
and
trying to go over
all the mistakes i made the first two
chapters and
not making them again because it just
made life difficult for me you know and
i've said this before you know
about
over 20 years ago i was sitting in my
i was in london actually at blake's
hotel
sitting sitting in uh on the phone with
richard harris and
richard gave me some really good advice
about he said mickey man
he said listen
you can't
beat him there's too many of them and
they got too much money and they've got
he says you just got to pull back and
and i got off the phone with richard and
i thought nah
i'm going to do it my way and you know
and i made a big mistake because
i really
richard had been there before me and i
really
was
about to take richard
sound good advice that he gave what have
you learned about yourself mickey in
this in this sounds a fascinating
journey you've been on here what have
you learned most about yourself
well you know the biggest thing was i
i came from a very
shameful upbringing and it was very
violent and very physical
abuse and mental
and i
when i left home at like 14 or 15.
i didn't realize
i was so happy that
the physical
pain was over because that was
horrifying
that went on for nearly 10 years but i
didn't realize that
it was going to
me up
in my head my way of thinking my way of
dealing with people because i
you know you have a choice when you're
when you
when you're abused
physically
uh at the time i wasn't thinking about
it mentally uh
you you
there comes a time
and it happened when i was about 14.
and when you're living in shame
it's a
there's nothing worse than that so
you got two choices
you either live in shame
and you become like a broken
soul a broken person
or you get hard
and
i chose to get hard
not by choice just by survival and
as the years passed and uh i messed
everything up that i tried to accomplish
you know i
i take the blame for it because
by me getting
hard
with everything and everybody
uh alienated me from
i became as my therapist told me
a scary person to deal with
and i didn't know how to turn the off
switch
off
and have you learned mickey have you
learned how to turn that off now
i've learned well it's interesting i
went to therapy for 23 years and i
i didn't ever think i would
but the therapist said to me one day he
said after about
three or four years
out of the 23 i went
he said you have absolutely no regard
for
repercussions or accountability
he says that's just not in your dna
and i realized with dealing with
people who deal from an authoritarian
place
producers who think that they can
treat you a certain way because they're
the ones with the money and the power
they finally ran into a cat they can
didn't give up
about their money you've got to watch
your language mickey i'm sorry i'm
afraid i have to apologize when you do
that but i understand why you feel this
way yeah i i apologize for it i'm just
saying
you know people have money in power they
really feel that they have a
this thing where they can
treat you a certain way
but
i made a decision
a long time ago when i was 14
that i got to be a man
and i had to be a man of 14
and later on
as the years went by even with the
success
and the and the destruction of my career
it was always important for me
because of where i came from
to be a man first
and then active second
i you know i interviewed just before the
wrestler came out and it was an
incredibly powerful interview because
you've been in the wilderness for so
long then
and then suddenly the wrestler came
along and propelled you back
to the top again
what was that moment
i'm back in the wilderness after the
wrestling
you don't really know are you i don't
think
not not really because what i learned to
do
was
i wasn't going to let anyone put me on
the shelf
yeah all right
because i want you to hate me
i've got enough ability and i've got
more ability than most actors that are
walking around
and if i could just behave myself
there's a lot of young up-and-coming
directors
that aren't afraid of what
how i used to be perceived
when you see when you see mickey when
you see someone like tom cruise
you know grossing a billion dollars with
top gun
maverick the sequel
35 years or so after the first one what
do you think of that
that doesn't mean to me the guy's been
doing the the same
part for 35 years you know there's you
know i mean
i got no respect for that
right i don't get i don't give no that's
r yeah really brother i don't care about
money and power i care about
when i watch al pacino work and chris
walken and and de niro's early work and
uh
richard harris's work and ray winstone's
work those are the kind of that's the
kind of actor i want to be like monty
cliff and you know brando back in the
day and a lot of
a lot of guys that just tried to stretch
his actors and be the you don't think
tom cruise is a good actor
i think he's irrelevant in my world
and says the next mickey wrote breaks
down remembering the time he met
russia's vladimir putin and reveals what
he said to the dictator now have you got
the chance
to let these people in ukraine be
independent in a
democratic society they want to live in
and just stop today stop now not
tomorrow just stop right now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the special edition of
piers morgan uncensored an unforgettable
interview with hollywood legend mickey
rourke his uncensored opinions and
public feuds have often landed him in
hot water but he always bounces back so
what does he make of today's cancel
culture and how does he survive it
what do you think when you see people
being cancelled for having an opinion
that happens all the time it's nothing
new but do you think he's right
uh
i would have to be given a specific uh
case well i'll give you one so macy gray
the singer came on my show last week and
said what her definition of a woman was
if i asked you what a woman is what
would you say
let's say a human being with uh boobs
how are you to start there yeah i mean
the dictionary is quite a straight
forward it just looks like an adult
female right i will say this and
everybody's going to hate me but as a
woman
just because you go change your parts
doesn't make you a woman right sorry
she got so much abuse for her honest
opinion that she had to go on the today
show in america and effectively back
down on her opinion which i thought was
ridiculous you were on the piers morgan
show and there was a question about
trans women i think that if you
in your heart feel that that's what you
are then that's what you are regardless
of what anybody says
or thinks you know what i'm saying i've
i've learned a lot absolutely and i'm
glad i did i don't think anybody should
have to uh apologize for what their
personal opinion is on
on any matter
uh unless their personal opinion is very
narrow-minded and it's going to hurt
other people
i think he shared his thoughts on
controversial russian president vladimir
putin following the invasion of ukraine
the pair met back in 2014 and earlier
this year he told fox nation he had
positive memories of meeting the russian
leader
made headlines all over the world and
his photograph wearing a t-shirt with
putin's face on it he described putin as
a man with empathy
you said some interesting stuff about
vladimir putin after you met him in 2014
you wore a t-shirt with his
his picture on it um yeah that okay that
was 2014. i know that's what i said yeah
so i wanted to ask you whether you're i
i just want to make that clear okay i
went over there 2014
and he there it was some sort of event
where some
uh entertainers from the states came
over and he was dancing with sharon
stone and he was he actually was singing
a song on a piano
and then he invited me specifically to
go
to his hometown in st petersburg
to visit a uh home
uh
that
took care of little tiny children that
had kind of incurable cancer
and
that was
really
heartbreaking to go to
and
i was talking to all these little kids
and i i remember i gave a rosary of mine
to one of the little girls
um
and i looked over at
vladimir
and i could see somebody
that was genuinely concerned
about
where we were
and
someone who
was empathetic and
he was there
for a sincere reason
how do you square that mickey with the
guy we see now illegally invading
ukraine and bombing little children to
pieces every single day
that's the thing that
blows my mind because it's like
it's like two brother countries and it's
like i don't understand what he wants
and it's like
not only combatants are getting killed
but old people are getting killed young
people are getting killed schools are
getting targeted hospitals are getting
target you know and all that not right
you know i saw
uh
i saw a guy an image of a man who was
looking in a hole in a ditch
and he was looking for
and i put myself in his position he was
looking for his brother
and
uh
that
kind of struck home with me
and bothered me a lot and maybe think
he's doing really terrible bad things
and
i wish some kind of little bell would
ring in his head or his heart
and he'd wake up and just stop all this
and then
i saw a picture of a man an old man
laying shot on him on a bicycle an old
woman shot on a bicycle
but the image that bothered me the most
was
i saw this old man
holding a a
a little grey kitten
and
the
old man survived
his house being bombed
and
he lost five family members
and the only thing he had
kind of hard for me to talk about it
the only thing he had was this little
gray kitty
and i
i looked at that image
image
sorry
and i i said
how can i have anything to worry about
losing a movie
somebody saying bad about me
or i'm having a bad day and i'm looking
at this old guy holding a little kitty
that crawled out from the rubble
and that's all he had
mickey when you talk so powerfully about
ukraine and what's happened to the
people there
you must think back to your experience
of meeting putin
and question
whether he really did have the ability
to be
i
empathetic
it with my i saw people don't want to
hear it i saw it with my own eyes
i saw it the way he treated me okay
but
being
something changed or
and all this mayhem and this death and
this killing
i didn't see that when i was at the
children's home
with the little kids that all had cancer
and and he was so genuine and empathetic
and and and
i saw
someone who really cared now people
might be mad at me for saying something
like that but i saw him at in 214. right
now what's going on right now i don't
i don't
i think i don't believe in that
war i think it's
it's it's terrible it's it's my best
friend in the world who i love more than
anybody is from ukraine he just got his
family out of nicolaive and
you know every day when dima who's
ukrainian comes to work with me
you know the first thing i say to him is
how how how's your mother house how's
your family house because
you know when demon knocks on the door
to come to work
what's going through my mind before he
opens the door is
he's going to tell me something
not good
what is your message for putin
if you had a chance to give it to him
you're not going to live forever
look at all look at you know
peter the great napoleon with the
what what happened to them trying to get
more and more and more and just you know
you've got your power your money just
live your life and you know let these
people in ukraine be independent in a
democratic society they want to live in
and
and just stop today stop now not
tomorrow just stop right now
and says the next mickey wrought reveals
how some choice words for president
trump attracted some unwanted attention
from the secret service
they called the united states of america
it's now the divided states of america
and
there's one big reason for that but i'm
not going to go into it because i don't
need another visit from the secret
service
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
uncensored my incredible interview with
hollywood's comeback king mickey raw
it's raw emotional engaging and
explosive i build him as a man who burns
every bridge in tinsel town and already
we've seen him burning tom cruise here's
a reminder
that doesn't mean the guy's been doing
the the same
part for 35 years you know there's you
know i mean
i got no respect for that
well the scathing comments made
headlines across the entire planet and
it was letting up as the interview
continued in the next part of the show
mickey opened up on why the only person
he won't be uncensored about is donald
trump
was it because of something he said
about president trump
yeah
what did you say about him
just the truth which is what
read my mind
what follow was a conversation that got
everybody gripping as it went on it was
so compelling i've started to do
something i've never done before i kept
taping with him after the show ended and
mickey went on to describe the time the
secret service came to visit his home
what do they say
a lot
and that's just way over my head
he also talks partying with tupac
uh we never saw the daylight
i
i don't i mean i love him i miss him
daily you know
we were very similar
we had a lot of stuff in common
uh
and we we loved each other you know
deeply and tells me how many times he's
truly been in love how many times have
you been would you say properly in love
in your life
once
once who with
you know with
turned out i did but first i want to
know what he makes for the state of
america today
mickey you recently posted a statue of
liberty uh crying it was an image of
statutory crying in tears
and you
captioned it with a lot of truth what
did you mean by that
well because they call it the united
states of america but it's it's it's now
the divided states of america
and there's one big reason for that but
i'm not going to go into it because i
don't need another visit from the secret
service
when did you have one before
oh about six months ago why
take a wild guess
was it because of something you said
about president trump
yeah
what did you say about him
just the truth
which is what
read my mind
and the secret service actually came to
see you
oh yeah
and what do they say
a lot
and that's just way over my head so i
got nothing to say anymore about nothing
are you still trying to
they're still trying to fit they're
still trying to figure out what happened
to kennedy's brain
all
right are you sad mickey about what's
happening to america
no because i've never felt comfortably
comfortable in this country to begin
with i've always enjoyed the uk
i've always enjoyed france i've always
enjoyed italy i've always enjoyed russia
i haven't been to the ukraine i can't go
right now
but i i've never really felt comfortable
in my own country really
i've always liked other countries better
what do you think over here
what do you feel about italy i think i'm
saying mickey that joe biden was the
first time you'd voted for any president
are you what do you think of how he's
doing
it's
he's doing
all he can do with the mess that he's
got on his hands
is he too old to take a job do you think
i don't i don't think it has anything to
do with his age i think it's going to
take another
after the last
thing it's going to take another 30
years for this country to
straighten itself out
if it ever can again
it's divided you can feel it
i've lost friends over it
uh
but i'm not gonna be outspoken about it
anymore i don't i don't need the fbi to
call me up and tell me that some
uh trump fanaticals got me on a hit list
and all that oh you know what
i'm moving to texas
my place is going to be fortified like
nobody's business
and if somebody wants to come through my
gates it's going to be the last two
steps they ever
mickey i wanted to talk to you also
about what happened to your friend
johnny depp what did you think of that
case and and
the fact that in the end he won it
well you know i i know i know johnny for
many years but i i don't really know
intimately
all i could say is i was in a situation
one time where i got blamed for
something that i didn't do
it cost me movie jobs for several years
and it caused me a bad reputation and
finally
the truth came out but the truth came
out after
i lost movies and i lost jobs and
and so i felt bad for somebody that uh
is getting trying to get chopped down by
some gold digger you know
you think that's what she was
absolutely
absolutely
you have a russian model girlfriend i
believe is that going well no no no no
that was several years ago
are you are you single now
i've been single for seven years
really
yeah do you like it that way
at the first four years it was really
lonely um
but i realized that i couldn't keep
i couldn't keep
going out with
women that
we're gonna
if i ever have a relationship ever again
i hope maybe somebody comes in my life
that i can trust
how many times how many times have you
been would you say properly in love
in your life
once
once who with
you know with
well you tell me
you tell me
uh i'll guess it was carrie
yes it was
she was the love of your life that was
23 years ago we haven't seen each other
or spoke
if you did see it what would you say
mickey
nothing
do you have any regrets about the way it
all ended
i've got a lot of regrets about a lot of
things
you know so
that contradicts that
frank sinatra song
yeah i did it my i did it my way but
he says too few too few to mention i got
too many to remember
and says the next invisible final part
of my entity with mickey roulette he
tells you why tyson fury will fight
again and what it was like to party with
a legendary rapper tupac shakur
we were very similar
we had a lot of stuff in common
and we we loved each other you know
deeply
and
i think about them all the time do you
yeah all the time
i know on a weekly basis practically
that's why he's putting his neck on the
block yet again this time working with
the fugitive child abuser roman polanski
i only know about
working with him as a director and
it being
one of my most pleasurable
experiences acting ever
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
welcome back in a moment we'll hear from
mickey rourke about his future his
legacy and why he's working with roman
polanski i'll also ask him about his now
legendary 30-year feud with former
co-star robert de niro first fell out
off-screen in the 1980s and they fell
out on screen too in the classic
thriller angel heart
i didn't want to cause a scene i hate to
have any sort of fuss
so i thought perhaps you could you know
subtly in a more quiet manner
you want me to check it out check it out
okay
yeah
it's funny i have a feeling i've met you
before
i don't know i don't think so
but first mickey's a lifelong boxer he
infamously quit acting to attempt to
come back himself and he's a big fan of
tyson fury does you think the world
heavyweight champion will ever fight
again and will he
what do you make of the way tyson fury
handles himself the the world
heavyweight i love i love tyson fury he
has so much ability it's not even funny
do you think he'll fight again he says
he's given up
every every fighter says he's giving
they've given up
and they all come back
how do you rate him in the pantheon of
heavyweight champs
excuse me how do you rate
uh one of the very best ever because of
his size but he's also a very fluid
fighter he he uses faints
he uses his jab
he's very intelligent he's got a very
extremely high boxing iq
and it's in his blood
and he
he knows how to pace himself
plus he takes one hell of a punch and
gets back up
who's when you were boxing mickey
obviously you got to know a lot of
boxers you got to know the art of boxing
you're a very good boxer yourself who is
the boxer in history of any weight
you would at least wanted to get in the
ring with
at their peak
well there's two different things there
there's there's
there's like a great fighter
like linux lewis
that
is eventually going to catch you
uh because of his height his reach his
boxing iq
and then there's the first four or five
rounds with mike tyson yeah
you know um
one fighter i i admire so much is from
your country is was henry cooper oh yeah
yeah yeah
well he could have beaten ollie couldn't
he he had a chance
well he actually did if the gloves
didn't get cut the time would have ran
out yeah that's what i mean yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah do you steal bulks mickey
and you yes i do
yeah
just i'm trying to decide i'm trying to
decide if i'm going to have one last one
mike tyson is still fighting why don't
you why don't you finally get in the
ring with tyson
test your theory i
i don't mess around with anything over
220 pounds
[Laughter]
how is uh how is your feud with robert
de niro going is that showing any sign
of
there's no views there's just a lot of
people trying to stir up you know i
don't i have
i have nothing
i have no feeling whatsoever on the
subject
who is the greatest actor you've ever
seen
aside from myself aside from yourself
no
i would say marlon brando monty cliff
richard harris
who
charles bronson
he was great he was great actually
but you are a great actor mickey i mean
you are one of the great actors when you
were on your absolute a game you were up
there with any of the greats i think
well i'm back on my a game
you think you still are no i know i i
know i am
are you considering any any roles at the
moment you think could show us
well i i had i just had a great
experience with roman polanski
i'm going to go over to paris to work
with uh jean renau and if it's a casel
and so we've got some very interesting
projects
lined up you know on polanski i mean
it's a it is a very controversial figure
polanski he is technically well a
fugitive in a child rapist well aside
from
yeah i don't know much about that
because he never went to court and there
were a lot of people that
uh
told their side of the story where
where he already had taken off so well
he did he didn't go to court he didn't
get a call mickey he got convicted and
then he had scones well
i don't know all about that i only know
about
working with him as a director and
it being
one of my most pleasurable
experiences acting ever and if i
if i could work with him one or two
times i would really be
very fortunate and very happy
so i loved i loved i loved working with
him
it doesn't it doesn't bother you that he
fled justice
no
really
yeah
i mean would you work for somebody like
harvey weinstein for example
knowing what you know now
uh
i turned down a couple jobs from harvey
weinstein
but i worked with him
i
i can't answer that
what's the moment mickey of your entire
career that if i had the ability to
let you relive it now
you would choose to relive
my career my life your career well i'll
come to your life as well but first your
career
i did a movie once that i was i they
paid me a lot of
enormous amount of money
and i was ashamed of doing it
i was ashamed that i sold out and that's
when i left
acting he went back to fighting for six
years and
so i really regretted doing this one
particular movie because they paid me a
lot of money and i went and bought a big
house and all that
which was the movie
harley davidson and the marlborough man
and if you had your time again you just
wouldn't do it absolutely
i loved working with don johnson it was
just
i didn't like the material or the dirt
the director was a
can i say
[Laughter]
what's next mickey what do you want to
achieve
you're a guy you said you're in your
third your third act now where are you
yeah the beginning first of all i'm
moving to texas
uh
i think that's going to be really good
for me to be in a place where i i i
don't know i could be around horses
which i love and
uh
i could
get myself very focused i could stay
keep myself in really good physical
shape and
mental shape
i've always kept my spirituality
very private but it's a very strong part
of my life
what do i want to do now and i and i
started doing this about two years ago
was when i get an opportunity to work
i do
i want to do the best job
in that
moment
that i could ever possibly give the
director
to do
in other words i'm not going to walk
through it i'm going to give him
everything i got
because
from now on every job i get they're
going to get all of me
what does it take mickey to be a truly
great actor
i think a lot of hard work and
discipline
and to be able to be brave enough to
make
choices
that are interesting choices that are
either going to be really really good
or terrible
and the other question i wanted to ask
you what was it like to party with
two-pack
we never saw the daylight
i
i don't i mean i love him i miss him
daily you know
we were very similar
we had a lot of stuff in common
uh
and we we loved each other you know
deeply
and uh
i think about them all the time do you
yeah all the time
i know on a weekly basis practically
you know you seem mickey and i don't
want us to sound patronizing but you
seem happier than i've known you for a
while more content in your own skin
perhaps
well you know i think
for some
strange reason the
the year and a half that i didn't leave
my house
and i brought all my weight equipment
and all my boxing equipment
and i isolated myself for a year and a
half
it helped me
kind of get centered about
my priorities and and to
the worst thing anybody can get is
bitter
and that's the one thing i said i would
never get
i remember several years ago being at
the cannes film festival and there was
an actor who used to be a movie star but
not anymore and all he was doing was
bad-mouthing
some actor and i was listening to him
going
besides the fact that you're a junkie
and an alcoholic
here you are badmouthing this guy
and it's like you're just a bitter
and i go i never want to get like that
you know people say to me what's your
best film
and i say i haven't made it yet
which is a great answer because it shows
that you look forward not back right
oh yeah
yeah with both hands
when you do finally have to look back
because you're no longer with us how
would you like to be remembered you
could write your own tombstone and it
said here lies mickey rourke he
i don't really care to be remembered
that way
really you don't want to be remembered
at all
that's not relevant to me
i'm looking forward to when i go to
heaven and i could see
where most of my friends are now
well some of them are in hell but i mean
i'm looking i'm looking forward to the
the next journey i mean i don't fear
death
i fear dying but i don't fear that
because
i truly believe it's going to be like a
big happy reunion who are you most
looking forward to seeing up in heaven
most of all my brother my little my
younger brother
joe
joey uh my grandmother
uh my father
uh
some aunts and uncles i didn't get to
know
uh
tupac
good good-looking thomas uh
uh
like to meet steve mcqueen paul newman
all those guys monty cliff
you know
so i i mean
there's more people that i love
i mean the older you get the more people
around you die i mean you know two
months ago ray leota was alive
two weeks ago jimmy khan was alive i
mean
i miss willie deville one of my favorite
singers you know
and it's like uh
i've got more people you know gone than
here so it's like
you know
i'm just that's just another journey
that i'm looking forward to
well so am i mickey it's been fantastic
to interview you thank you so much for
all your time i really appreciate it
okay thank you very much well there you
have it a remarkable interview with a
remarkable hollywood character that's
all for tonight whatever you're up to
this evening like mickey rook keep it
unsensing good night
join me ian collins every day on talk tv
there is nothing we hate more than
hypocrisy discussing the big issues why
was it so hard to establish the deputy
leader was at a meeting with her
colleagues the callers alan in grimsby
tracy in burton on trent dave thank you
very much picking apart the big step
this simply does not wash look who's
back under the spotlight
[Music]
this is talk tv news
[Music]
good evening i'm zoro zimmerman delays
will last into the weekend after a
critical incident was declared at the
port of dover which saw holiday makers
stuck in six hour queues british police
blamed france whilst the french have
blamed eurotunnel the rmt has confirmed
next week's planned rail strike will go
ahead 40 000 workers at network rail and
14 train companies will walk out next
wednesday
and talk tv and the sun will be hosting
a conservative leadership debate between
rishi sunak and liz trust next week you
can watch the sun showdown the fight for
number 10 hosted by talk tv's political
editor kate mccann and the sun's
political editor harry cole from 6pm
next tuesday that's all for now we'll
have more after the talk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you